Ласкаво просимо у конфлікт зон
Дуже дякую Саро
минулими тижнями українські міста
розташовані далеко від лінії фронту у
тому числі і столиця країни Київ
прокидалися від масованих ударів з
повітря які очевидно були спрямовані
проти цивільної інфраструктури Як ви
думаєте чого хоче досягти Путін цим
ударами
Я думаю мета полягає у тому щоб знизити
рішучість українців чинити опір
жорстокому російському вторгненню але я
також думаю Путін зазнає невдачі як він
зазнав невдачі у всіх інших спробах
взяти під контроль Україну після
вторгнення у лютому це показує
жорстокість війни на наших очах гине
цивільне населення атакують об'єкти
критичної інфраструктури тому Важливо
щоб НАТО а також союзники та партнери
НАТО продовжували надавати підтримку
Україні З цією метою Минулого тижня
члени НАТО зобов'язалися надати Україні
більше систем протиповітряної оборони та
іншу допомогу як ви чекайте цього бути
достатньо щоб зупинити російські удари
із застосуванням зброї великої дальності
зокрема безпілотників
має величезне значення українці вже
досягли успіху збивши багато російських
ракети безпілотників в майбутньому
ситуація зміниться Ще сильніше бо зараз
активізуються союзники так Німеччина
щойно поставила дуже просунуто новітню
систему ППО на зустрічі міністрів
оборони країн НАТО Минулого тижня США та
ще кілька союзників оголосили про
виділення Україні нових систем та
великої кількості боєприпасів та
матеріалів для існуючих систем і це має
значення українці вже зараз здатні збити
безліч ракет та безпілотників ви кажете
що вони змінять ситуацію в майбутньому
про яке майбутні йдеться президент
Зеленський заявив що внаслідок
російських атак було знищено 30%
українських електростанцій зима швидко
наближається люди можуть мати складнощі
з опаленням своїх будинків як швидко
можуть бути доставлені в Україну системи
ППО особливо з огляду і ви це визнали на
проблеми з виробництвом на заході
система зброї які поставили союзники її
партнери НАТО уже мали великий вплив це
одна з причин чому Росія не змогла
досягти переваги у повітрі контролю над
повітряним простором України і це було
великою проблемою для російських військ
упродовж усієї війни Вони очікували що
візьмуть під контроль повітряний простір
і не змогли цього досягти це сталося
звісно насамперед через уміння рішучість
українських збройних сил використовувати
старі радянські засоби ппу які вони вже
мали союзники НАТО постачали українцям
боєприпаси для цих старих систем а потім
почали надавати їм нові системи
останній приклад німецька система яка
демонструє що Німеччина зараз справді
постачає Україні важливі потужності їхні
значення в майбутньому тільки зростатиме
зима наближається і це також було
основним посилом на зустрічі міністрів
оборони НАТО тому Нам необхідно
збільшити постачання усього починаючи із
зимового одягу генераторів наметів щоб
ми могли гарантувати що українці зможуть
продовжувати військові дії усю зиму
давайте ще трохи поговоримо про
невідкладність дій та звернемо увагу на
поле бою Україна Як ми знаємо відвойовує
територією на Сході та півдні але є
повідомлення що наступ на Донбасі
практично зупинився тим часом російські
підкріплення прибувають на фронт
намагаючись переламати перебіг подій в
Україні Наскільки критичним Ви бачите
цей момент зараз не в майбутньому прямо
зараз для контрнаступу України з
настанням холодної пори року
війни за своєю природою не передбачувані
і звичайно ж в Україні російські війська
мають ще багато можливостей те що ми
спостерігали за останні тижні та дні це
насправді найсерйозніша ескалація
конфлікту з моменту вторгнення у лютому
бо якщо скласти разом їхні мобілізацію
та сили які вони зараз можуть відправити
на фронт з їхньої частковою Тепер уже з
незаконною анексією української
території та небезпечною ядерною
риторикою усе це є Найбільшою ескалацією
з початку війни Отже знову ж таки нам
потрібно просто посилити нашу підтримку
і звичайно ж ця підтримка виявилася
надзвичайно важливою тому що це
дозволило українцям спочатку витіснити
росіян з Території навколо Києва потім
зупинити російський наступ на Донбасі а
потім розпочати Контрнаступ під час
якого вони змогли повернути великі
території на Донбасі а також тиснути на
російські сили на Херсонщині
кажуть що їм потрібно більше Тан тому що
просуватися вперед ми говоримо сьогодні
з Берлінського зовнішньополітичного
форуму Німеччина - член НАТО
критикується за те що не постачає
Україні більш важку військову техніку в
тому числі танки Леопард 2 на вашу думку
чи має Німеччина зараз постачати танки
Україні
Німеччина надала та надає Україні багато
необхідної техніки включаючи передові
системи ППО та іншу сучасну зброю а
також боєприпаси та артилерію інші
союзники надали аналогічну допомогу а
деякі з них також надали бронетехніку та
багато іншої надзвичайно важливої
допомоги для України пане генеральний
секретар Я просто хотіла б наголосити на
важливості того що ми чули і згадати
цитату наприклад міністра оборони Латвії
я зачитаю її вам він каже якби Німеччина
надала Україні пропорційно до того що ми
надали ця війна Закінчилася чи потрібно
Німеччині та іншим великим державам
робити зараз більше
зараз потрібно робити більше це було
послання міністрів оборонний НАТО коли
ми зустрічалися Минулого тижня також
були зроблені нові оголошення про
додаткові поставки крім того нам варто
усвідомити що допомога надана досі
Україні виснажила наші власні запаси на
якісь стадії ми більше не зможемо
продовжувати це робити Таким чином нам
потрібно нарощувати виробництво і це
було наступним посланням міністрів
оборонних країн НАТО тепер ми
безпосередньо взаємодіємо з
промисловістю щоб поповнити наші запаси
боєприпасів і техніки тоді ми зможемо
одночасно підтримувати на належному
рівні власних стримування та оборону і
водночас продовжувати надавати підтримку
Україні
давайте ще трохи поговоримо про
нарощування виробництва і той факт що
воно зараз просідає але спочатку Путін
каже що він використовуватиме і я цитую
тут такі наявні систему озброєнь для
захисту території це сприймається Як
погано завуальоване ядерна загроза цього
тижня НАТО проводить планові ядерні
навчання щорічні російські навчання
зазвичай відбувається наприкінці жовтня
наскільки сильно зараз ви стурбовані тим
що російські навчання можуть бути
використані для проведення ядерної зброї
у стан підвищеної бойової готовності
до уважно стежимо за тим що вони роблять
ми пильні і звичайно ж особливо зараз
коли Вони збираються провести ядерні
навчання при цьому ризик будь-якого
ядерного нападу на Україну застосування
ядерної зброї проти України низький
однак потенційний вплив його
застосування та наслідки дуже великі Тож
до цього ризику ми маємо поставитись
серйозно І ми робимо це чітко
повідомляючи Росії що на неї чекають
серйозні наслідки якщо вона застосує
ядерну зброю в Україні
а також нагадуємо Росії про те що ядерну
війну неможливо виграти тож Ніколи не
варто починати і ми звичайно зберігаємо
пильність І уважно стежимо за тим що
вони роблять поки що ми не спостерігаємо
жодних змін у їхній ядерній політиці то
ядерні готовності але це те за чим ми
постійно стежимо особливо зараз коли
вони проводять ядерні навчання
але враховуючи удар по мосту через
керченську протоку в окупованому Криму
на початку жовтня та нещодавне
звільнення Україною території на півдні
та сході країни Як ви вважаєте
принижений Путін зараз більш схильний
завдати удару
Я буду обережний розмірковуючи про різні
ризики та різні сценарії ми маємо бути
готові до будь-яких сценаріїв І ми
готові до них нас неможливо ні залякати
ні змусити миритися з шантажем Росії Я
думаю що ядерна риторика і ті загрози
які ми чули від Росії мають
наметішинтежувати і змусити припинити
надавати підтримку Україні але якщо ми
це зробимо то в Україні переможе
президент Путін якщо він переможе в
Україні це надійшли дуже небезпечний
сигнал усім авторитарним лідерам про те
що якщо вони застосують військову силу
жорстоким чином порушуючи міжнародне
право то досягнуть своїх цілей це
зробить нас більш уразливими це зробить
світ більш небезпечним а тому так ризики
є при усіх варіантах у цьому конфлікті
Але я думаю що ризик дозволити
президенту Путіну перемогти набагато
вищий ніж продовжувати підтримувати
Україну
ви її члени НАТО наголосили яцитую Росія
повинна зрозуміти що ядерну війну
неможливо виграти і ніколи не можна
вести Чи є у Вас якісь гарантії щоб
Путін почує це послання
частково тому що процес тільки разів
заявляли Сполучені Штати та інші
союзники по НАТО які володіють ядерною
зброєю але також обійшлося і від імені
усього Альянсу і Крім того Росія сама
була згодна з цим твердженням це
загальновідомо сюди
ви попередили про серйозні наслідки які
саме
ніколи не будемо називати подробиць того
як саме ми реагуватимемо частково тому
що це сильно залежатиме від виду атаки
обставин контексту коли також і тому що
ми ніколи не дамо потенційному
противнику привілей знати як саме ми
реагуватимемо Вони знають що це матиме
серйозні наслідки і ми повторювали це
повідомлення кілька разів за останні
тижні
але чи всі 30 союзників з НАТО згодні з
тим якою буде відповідь
усі союзники з НАТО погоджуються з
серйозністю будь-якого застосування
ядерної зброї і про це недвозначно
говорив я та багато інших союзників НАТО
крім того Я думаю нам потрібно
розрізняти застосування зброї масового
знищення чи ядерної зброї в Україні та
будь-який напад на союзника по НАТО
напад на члена НАТО звичайно ж призведе
до застосування статті 5 про колективну
оборону і щоб не було місця для
прорахунків для нерозуміння в Москві з
цього приводу ми збільшили нашу
військову присутність у східній частині
Альянсу підвищили готовність наших сил
щоб переконатися що напад на союзника по
НАТО безумовно викличе відповідну
реакцію всього Альянсу і ми робимо Це не
для того щоб спровокувати конфлікт а для
того щоб запобігти конфлікту щоб
зберегти мир і це в основному те саме що
НАТО робило понад 70 років коли
стикалися з ядер загрозою або викликом з
боку Радянського Союзу
миядерною війною і безпосередньо не
вступатиму у війну в Україні навіть якщо
Москва вдарить по Україні ядерною зброєю
чи має він рацію
тому що ми чітко заявили будуть серйозні
наслідки Але ми не вдавалися до
подробиць які саме це будуть наслідки і
звичайно ми маємо багато способів
реагування і це саме те про що ми
сказали
хоча би попередили Москву про серйозні
наслідки французькі президенти Мануель
макрон заявив що Франція не
використовуватиме ядерну відповідь на
застосування Росією свого ядерного
Арсеналу проти України чи регіону ця
заява не дуже допомагає вашим заходам
стримування чи не так
у
нас є різні способи реагування це не
обов'язково має бути застосування
ядерної зброї ми знову і знову заявляємо
що обставини за яких розглядатиме
можливість застосування ядерної зброї
залишаються дуже віддаленими однак це не
скасовує можливості відповіді НАТО та
союзників Альянсу в разі застосування
Росією ядерних зброї проти України
що підтримка України західними державами
А ви згадали про те що саме країни НАТО
надсилають в Україну начебто робить їх
стороною конфлікту оскільки члени НАТО
надають більшу частину військової
підтримки чи складною буде не виглядати
як повноцінна сторона конфлікту
тому що ми не є стороною конфлікту це
означає що ми не маємо своїх військових
сил на тій території ми не беремо участь
у бойових діях але ми підтримуємо
Україну Україна має право на самооборону
це право закріплено у договорі ООН кожна
нація має право захищатись від
загарбницької війни жорстокого нападу
який ми бачили щодо України і союз
Чемпіонату допомагають Україні
відстоювати це право на самооборону але
це не робить нас стороною конфлікту
Я хотіла би запитати вас про розширення
НАТО зокрема про те що Президент України
Володимир Зеленський оголосив про заявку
на прискорений вступ в НАТО він вказав
на приклади Фінляндії Швеції чи
погодитися ви на прискорений розгляд
заявки від України протягом найближчих
12 місяців Немає нічого нового у тому що
Україна прагне вступити в НАТО позиція
Альянсу залишається незмінною двері НАТО
відчинені ми продемонстрували це
останніми роками у відносинах з
Північною Македонією та чорногорією а
також з фінляндією та швецією і звичайно
ми також рішуче заявили що кожна країна
має право обирати свій власний шлях
включаючи зрозуміло Україно зрештою
рішення про членство ухвалюватимуть 30
союзників НАТО та Україна Росія тут
немає право голосу зрозуміло Зараз наша
основна ува зосереджена на тому щоб
Україна виграла війну і тому ми
фокусуємось на підтримці України
але Питання в тому
чи б країни на прискорене членство
підтримую прийняті нами рішення які
полягають у тому що двері НАТО
залишаються відчиненими І що Україна
Одного дня стане членом Альянсу але в
короткостроковій перспективі пріоритетом
є надання підтримки Україні Щоб дати їй
можливість досягти більших успіхів на
полі бою а потім забезпечити закінчення
війни таким чином щоб Україна залишалася
суверенною незалежною державою в Європі
це є попередньою умовою для обговорення
питання про членство в НАТО
однак ви підтримали заявку Фінляндії та
Швеції і я хотіла би процитувати вас
вийшли і сказали що це буде історичний
момент Чому ви ухиляєтесь від чіткої
відповіді чи підтримуєте Україну в
прискореному вступі в НАТО
Ukraine
до переконаний що становище України
відрізняється від Фінляндії та Швеції
Фінляндія та Швеція давні партнери НАТО
У нас є консенсус в альянці щодо їхнього
членства в НАТО ми ухвалили це рішення
на саміті Мадриді у травні в Україні
зараз триває війна і тому головним
пріоритетом є надання військової
підтримки Україні як ми це робимо як
союзники та партнери НАТО і ця військова
підтримка є безпрецедентною І вона
справді допомогла українцям досягти
успіхів на полі бою звісно Перемоги на
полі бою це заслуга хоробрих українських
солдатів але без підтримки союзників з
НАТО вони не змогли б досягти цих
успіхів і не відкинути російські сили
настільки як ми це бачили протягом
останніх тижнів якщо озирнутися назад то
в 2008 році НАТО пообіцяла що Україна
зрештою стане членом Альянсу Україна
Звісно це задокументувала Невже НАТО всі
ці роки давало Україні марні надії
Альянс як раніше прагне цього але з 2008
року основна увага приділяється реформам
нарощуванню потенціалу підтримці України
у просування до членства в НАТО
Наскільки я знаю країни Євросоюзу
працюють з Україною рухаючись до
членства України в ЄС але звісно з 2014
року ми у ситуації коли Росія анексувала
Крим та взяла під контроль Східну
частину Донбасу тому основний акцент
було зроблено на наданні військової
підтримки України і союзники з НАТО
особливо Сполучені Штати Великобританія
Канада навчали та оснащували Українські
сили не з лютого 2022 року а з 2014-го І
це забезпечило те що Українські збройні
сили зараз набагато більші набагато
краще навчені і краще оснащення ніж 2014
року і це має значення на полі бою
голова британського центру кіберрозвідки
описав безпеку загрозу що походить від
Росії як вплив на погоду тоді як Китай
впливає на клімат як ви вважаєте які
урок можна отримати з підтримки
союзниками України проти вторгнення РФ
якщо Китай спробує вторгнутись або
незаконно анексувати територію
це завжди неприйнятно коли одна країна
намагається захопити землю іншої країни
тому ми так різко відреагували у
відповідь на російське вторгнення в
Україну Це найбільше захоплення земель з
часів Другої світової війни у Європі
тому ми передаємо Китаю що Звісно Вони
мають принаймні засудити незаконну війну
Росії проти України і ще одна з причин
чому ми отримуємо Україну Так ми
посилюємо сигнал усім іншим авторитарним
лідерам що ми не приймаємо такої
поведінки
Минулого тижня ви сказали що союзникам
довелося добре перевернути свої
військові арсенали щоб відправити
вантажі в Україну чи були члени НАТО не
задоволені адже якщо подивитися лише на
першу половину року лише 9 членів НАТО
витрачали на оборону два відсотки ВВП
або більше Зараз схоже точиться боротьба
за створення запасів та збільшення
виробничих потужностей і це відбувається
на тлі важких економічних часів чи зможе
це залишитися пріоритетом
я наполягав ми наполягали на збільшені
інвестиції в оборону в усьому альянсі
протягом багатьох років і звичайно ми
хотіли б бачити ще більше витрат на
оборону тим не менше те що ми
спостерігаємо з 2014 року є найбільшим
зміцненням колективної оборони НАТО з
моменту закінчення холодної війни до
2014 року союзники НАТО скорочували
витрати на оборону з 2014 року всі
союзники з НАТО збільшили витрати на
оборону на сотні мільярдів доларів і ми
підвищили свою боєздатність Уперше в
історії ми маємо бойові групи у східній
частині Альянсу і все це було викликано
російською анексією Криму та контролем
над східним Донбасом тому ми були готові
до вторгнення у лютому Ми попереджали
про нього з осені Минулого року
обмінювалися розвід даними проточні
плани Росії щодо вторгнення в Україну і
вдень вторгнення ми активізували наші
плани оборони та ще більше збільшили
нашу військову присутність на сході
блокунберг чи має Путін піти щоб було
досягнуто врегулювання в Україні так чи
ні
знову ж таки я не буду ви не змусите
мене відповідати на це запитання так чи
ні Ми реагуватимемо на дії Росії
незалежно від того хто там керує і ми
продовжуватимуть закликати їх припинити
цю війну саме президент Путін розпочав
цю війну і саме президент Путін може
закінчити її завтра вивівши свої війська
Ми повинні пам'ятати Якщо Путін та Росія
припинить воювати настане мир якщо
президент Зеленський та Україна
припинять воювати Україна перестане
існувати як незалежна держава і ми не
хочемо щоб це сталося саме тому ми
підтримуємо Україну
Дякую що приділили нам час
Дякую за запрошення
[музика]